[Music]
hey you guys remember
the duck sauce killer yeah he killed all
the delivery guys with the with the
fridge full of ducks yes yeah so much
dog sauce
this has quick irrational a quick recap
this guy ordered uh food from a chinese
restaurant the delivery guy went over
there and i guess he forgot
the duck sauce or the right amount of
duck sauce
so the
customer
followed that chinese delivery man and
killed him
and then when they went into his place
they went to the killer's uh house they
found a refrigerator full of duck sauce
he was like a crazy hoarder but he
wanted room temp duck duck sauce yeah
because once it gets cold it's all
congealed you know so yeah that was a
really big thing because you know
innocent asian guy got killed all over
so so sad
do you guys all like cold water like you
prefer room temp water ice cold ice cold
ice cold right on a hot day yeah
nikki likes room type water it's [ __ ]
weird yeah i think it's strange i know a
couple people like that and i think
they're [ __ ] weird too i think
they're strange yeah i don't really
respect it supposed to be healthier for
you
did you love her less when you found out
yeah what's the health benefit
like chinese people always talk about
drinking hot water and cold water it
absorbs better yeah naturally your body
is is not meant to go into a cold shock
internally anyway your body already has
a temperature that is warmer than
natural temperature so when you drink
warm water it assimilates quicker it's
like natural to your system you drink
cold water it technically cold like
chills things out and makes it react in
different ways but it makes you tougher
dog everyone that tells you that though
they look like they're going to die
and then everyone that drinks ice cold
water has a six-pack yeah but they but
they look like they're gonna die but
they [ __ ] last until the [ __ ] 400
year old mark that's true they're an
american ninja warrior yeah tough
mudders that's literally the toughest
thing you could ever [ __ ] do ninja
warrior american ninja warrior that
guy's drinking cold water no guys can
beat that [ __ ] american gladiators so
remember when this guy uh he got
arrested we i remember uh we were all
like what the [ __ ] because he he got out
on like 500k bail yeah and uh we're
first we're like how [ __ ] do you pay
that yeah but i guess his brother paid
it through a check that was from the
bank account of him
so like it came from him anyway somehow
uh and we were all like i'll [ __ ] let
a guy like that out that was the main
outrage right yeah so um he was due in
court
just a few days ago
uh you know for the hearing for all the
charges and everything how does a guy
like that get out dude hours before
he was set to be in the courtroom he
shot himself in the head whoa
not surprised but also that's why you
don't let [ __ ] guys like that out on
bail right killed himself that guy is a
[ __ ] weirdo though no you do let guys
like that out on bill because if they're
willing to pay 500 000 and then still
off themselves afterwards but i wouldn't
even be i wouldn't be surprised if he
did a david blaine trick too he's like
i'm i'm trick i'm trapping myself in ice
and we'll see how how long i make it
above times square
you don't know what someone like this is
going to do is the [ __ ] wild and he
has a fridge full of duck sauce yeah and
maybe he's like if i can't have duck
sauce ever again i can't i can't go back
in there man there's no duck sauce well
you compare this story to like say kane
velasquez right you guys heard about him
yeah this dude he tried he was opening
fire on uh
two guys that were accused of molesting
a son or something like that oh yeah
this is a norcal right yeah there's an
old crowd this dude is still in jail
since that story he's been he's been
denied bail like five times because it's
in san francisco and people like are
writing letters to the the judge like
hey you know let this guy out dana
white's writing letters like this guy's
a good guy let him off at least i think
governments
i actually think governments don't like
vigilantism more than
actual crime yeah and the reason why i
think is because it discredits their
authority and it discredits their
like image of we got [ __ ] under control
yeah so it hurts their feelings yeah
because when you give like like when you
make these guys into heroes right what
it's really saying is they're above the
law
and that the city's failing so batman if
they could they would grab batman and
commissioner gordon would like [ __ ]
put like he would put him in the slammer
for 80 years no commissioner gordon's
friend though you're cutting them like
you're you're invalidating there but
it's san francisco gotham city it's like
when i water nicki's plants and she's
like why did you do that and i'm like oh
because it just looked like they needed
a drink and then she's like but i don't
know how much you put in there like
everything you just took my job from me
i know what the [ __ ] to do
like i just usurped her authority
you guys need to fix that problem in the
relationship here's my system it's a
huge problem so uh
just like you said about how dare you
steve right like this guy the guy who uh
the murderer yeah he he should have been
in jail too between the year 1995 and
2012 he's been arrested nine times see
what the [ __ ] is this about dude
how do you get arrested nine times not
go away some of the arrests are sealed
so they don't know what he did but some
of them also say that he for robbery
with a gun nick's pissed and i'm i
actually agree with him yeah dude thank
you robbery with the gun yeah that's one
of the unsealed uh arrest documents so
they know that he has done violence why
do they seal documents for stuff like
that i don't does anyone know that well
yeah it protects us from things like the
epstein client list
shows
the list
show us list yeah i don't understand how
repetitive offenders just keep being let
out do nine times
that's a lot of anything we have this
three strike system where you get life
no not if you're not if you're white oh
yeah yeah okay okay okay well i liked it
because it's like baseball and i think
baseball rules are pretty good it's easy
to understand yeah yeah can't they at
least have a reasonable like six strikes
you're out or something like that
six strikes let's double up let's go
five all i'm saying is this [ __ ]
got nine
is there enough space in jail though
but we don't know if all of them are
felonies you know but nine arrests yeah
well most crimes are committed by
repetitive offenders though not
first-timers so all it's like the people
that get out they're probably gonna go
[ __ ] up another person's life
statistically speaking absolutely yeah
so like what is what are we supposed to
do then like just keep them locked up
like execution bring that back like i
don't know man like this guy tries to
pull the gun me i shoot him in my house
i go to jail like what the [ __ ] is the
problem i know i don't know man that's
so [ __ ] what do we do but yeah that's
that's we should listen to our
government and just follow whatever
they're like just okay just call the
police it's like i can't the gun's in my
face
like how am i supposed to call the
police yeah this dude killed a totally
innocent man like without any yeah
there's just no reason to and then they
go you should have called the police and
then do you see that lady crying she
goes we did and we try to tell them that
this guy was yeah yeah so he showed up
at the restaurant a total different time
with a gun yeah so they already knew he
was a threat but they didn't arrest they
didn't like do anything they didn't
arrest them and they didn't look at his
[ __ ] nine prior arrests like they're
like our favorite dancer said six
strikes and you're out yeah
you're at nine so that's what we're
going on it's like playing a horse but
with kin just the word
don't
don't say kendra's when we're talking
about murder videos you [ __ ] you
are what oh
you guys are killing it on the phone or
what
hey remember you're white you can't
speak on this topic wait uh i could
literally buy illegal kids murders right
now
this is a threat to you i'm gonna buy a
[ __ ] sweatshirt right now do it
because of this i am
[Laughter]
just make sure it's a [ __ ] two-piece
tracksuit it's nice oh there's a fake
tracksuit oh you should get one or just
make one you guys have a real track shoe
no because it's stupid and ugly
[Laughter]
this is ugly dude that's like versace
bro you should tell that to me i like
versace
yeah thank you you should talk to all
this all the russians so speaking of uh
speaking of mccain velasquez uh did he
actually kill anybody no he just shot
someone's hand okay so he can't get on
bail even though he shot somebody's hand
but this guy has fully killed an
innocent person but he was on bail
it's what joe's saying the whole
vigilante theme
and the and the worst part is he had so
many clues that he was like a unstable
individual but i think also the justice
system tends to coddle like mental
health a little too much instead of
looking at it like oh this guy could be
a [ __ ] crazy guy he could be he could
be like we could be empathetic towards
someone's mental health issues but if
they're also violent violent and
attacking people then we have to do both
we have to but you can't keep them caged
up like an animal oh yes we can put them
in your house then that's what i'm
saying like what is an attack too
because like honestly i feel attacked
because anthony thinks that my jumpsuit
sucks so it's like
and honestly think and know are two
different things my friend but like it
just depends on like how you feel it's
like what do i feel like somebody say
words are violent
sick i got our names let's see let's see
how many stars you got and how many
people have reviewed it please do but
yeah let's do a review on
gold jumpsuit it's not gonna be that
easy because i had to put this one
together actually a lot of women's ones
oh really yeah i did actually the the
code is separate than the pants
oh yeah you guys won't get that it
doesn't come in here i wouldn't be able
to tell hey 159 people
five stars
wow they have great taste can we read
some reviews real quick yeah we'll find
out it's a great jacket oh look at that
i love love love my jacket had designed
for my birthday it turned out perfect
exactly
that was designed for somebody else's
birthday
someone would who gave a two-star review
said she's very small run small i
disagree
it runs true to size runs exactly right
i think they're all new jersey house
wives they might be they could be
wow only three percent of people were
dissatisfied with this uh tarnishing
it's great look at the pants there's the
pants there's the pencils the pellets
are hidden
so how do you feel now anthony lee yeah
like [ __ ] yet yeah you feel like [ __ ]
you feel like being moated right you
just got motivated yeah i'm already big
everyone likes is close
yeah you're the only one i'm so
motivated dude the reviews are in bro
part of the three percent brother i'm
i'm literally the worst human being in
the world i purchased these for an event
and they were perfect great look at this
nice couple look at these nice people
look see
look at that see i should die yeah
you